so you're 23 now yeah the all thing for
you is that because you've grown up
being on screen yeah you've never kind
of had to do the awkward teenage thing
you've never had you know how you did
but it was on camera I think I could
speak freely that we've probably all had
slightly awkward T's no eric mccormack
you posted this picture so it's not like
I broke into your house and found it how
old were you in this picture
rollers face I was 15 32
you've grown into yourself yet figured
out how to pluck the center who was the
boy who played the incredible it was up
new fringo wit flu little David Cassidy
thank you
yes thank you I was just about to star
in my high school production of Godspell
when I did a short fringe but such long
at the back picture of you I think it's
a particularly American thing that some
American girls do look about 45
[Applause]
I'm done here it's it's it's got life in
it does solids you could write pencils
in that fall that was my high school
graduation photo did you think this way
I grew up in rural Rhode Island and I
think that I knew that I had to find
some drama like okay perfectly as well
the school did an amazing they did right
because that's more than one lights like
this they went all out in East Greenwich
Rhode Island yes I feel in Lewisham they
didn't
[Applause]
questions
I'm not refer to these as the bad years
well I think that that's I'm 15 years of
age I'm on an Easter egg hunt I'm too
old for let's be honest children over
here crying feels like an anxiety dream
yes I just smashed the Easter egg cut it
looks like um Evert police evidence
doesn't it yeah the colossi honey let's
talk about the fringe you were you were
talking to him about the friends that
went way to say my age in those photos
yeah
time to maintain Hollywood is it
let's bump it up those two photos next
to each other a serial killer
[Applause]
[Music]
you